71 million more people are facing
poverty that's according to a new u.n
study it says it's the consequence of
soaring food and energy prices unleashed
from russia's war in ukraine households
are scrimping charities are scrambling
for donations and families are under
pressure
in this plantation in bannon yossiane
hodonu is choosing a batch of cooking
bananas
at her meal she will turn them into
plaintained flour a locally produced
alternative to wheat flour her little
shop has almost doubled its production
since the beginning of the russian
invasion of ukraine
[Applause]
before the war in ukraine i produce at
least 80 kilos per month
but now i produce up to 150 kilos per
month when the market is on
the war quickly aggravated the dire
inequalities already caused by the kavin
19 pandemic and climate change over the
last couple of years
as a consequence west africa and many
other poor countries are now facing
their worst food security crisis since
the start of the world food program zero
angers initiative in 2015. with kovid
what we saw is effects that work through
labor markets lockdowns uh and income
that was slow and cumulative but had a
very strong impact uh over time so the
official estimates are about 125 million
people falling into poverty over about
18 months so what we find right now is
that three months of inflation have
drawn about 71 million people into
poverty
today more than 828 million people are
undernourished worldwide it's 150
million more than 2021. it's a dire
reminder of how the rise in inflation
and the global disruption of supply
chains can drive inequalities affecting
hundreds of million of poor people
around the world
harald von vitska is an agricultural
economist at humboldt university in
berlin he joins me for more
uh food supplies have been massively hit
over the past few months we've been
talking about this since the beginning
of the war can we say whether the
situation is getting better or worse
it has gotten worse worth worse and it's
a matter of both as increasing scarcity
on international agricultural commodity
markets and it's a matter of
distribution
and it's a combination of two things
one is that the times of plenty are over
in world agriculture the world food
economy has entered a new era of
scarcity what we've seen since 2000 is
that agricultural commodity prices have
tended to rise and on top of this
we have the
war in ukraine which is aggravating
things even more
in 2000 the price of wheat was at 2.50
per bushel before the war um
in ukraine this number had doubled to
five dollars per bushel and we are now
at 8.50 so three times more than three
times what the price of wheat was around
the turn of the millennium and it is
clear that this must have a significant
impact on hunger around the world and in
my book we are close to 1 billion humans
who are hungry right now those are
people who have 1.90 or less per person
and they in
purchasing power and we have to spend 70
or more of the amiga income on food and
it's quite clear that
this must significantly increase hunger
around the world what about efforts to
offset some of those uh aberrations in
trade routes that have been caused by
the war efforts by ngos efforts by
groups to push more uh trade to other
places even by nations such as brazil
for example filling in more with wheat
where in where nations like india pull
back is that making any kind of
difference in the short term
in the short term we have indeed the
potential to increase
food supplies around the world and one
of the most significant sources would be
to get ukrainian grain and other
agricultural commodities to the world
markets for this to actually happen
however we need at least a ceasefire
in that part of the world but also the
european union has some potential to
mobilize additional resources for food
crop production by discontinuing
temporarily the greening program which
acts to take
land out of agricultural commodity
production i want to ask you really
briefly is it possible that the rising
price of wheat will actually encourage
more planting that in the middle term
could actually answer some of these
problems that may not help in the short
term
yes and that is happening already every
year by on my book we lose four and a
half million
hectares in
natural habitats because of acreage
expansion and these high prices
dramatically increase the incentives for
an additional increase of the
agricultural
acreage around the globe with
dramatic
consequences for climate and uh
biodiversity all right we'll have to
leave it there howard von vitska with
humble university in berlin i'm afraid
we're going to leave it there thank you
very much